eniac78 asks me why did coinbase fold so
easy uh in reference to them uh saying
they're not gonna do their len product i
think maybe
uh brian armstrong
came on very strong with the sec in that
tweet storm and maybe the sec said
listen
we're on the same page here we both want
to protect customers we both want
innovation and gensler and whoever
said
let's work together and maybe we could
tone down the rhetoric and work together
and that would be a better process so
i'm guessing somebody came in
could be a venture capitalist could be a
politician could be an advisor to
coinbase uh could be somebody in the sec
and said hey can we just sit down for a
second and discuss this we heard your
criticisms publicly
we'd like to address them but if we're
going to have this
you know addressing and airing of
grievances can we agree that we're going
to
uh tone things down and not make it a
public spectacle because a public
spectacle like this
probably doesn't benefit either party it
makes coinbase look
you know confrontational maybe a little
defensive on the margins it makes
the sec
look like they're got maybe got some
nefarious reason for doing what they're
doing and that might actually not be the
case it could be and i i suspect
the sec wants to pump the brakes and not
see consumers get hurt and coinbase
wants to move fast because they're a
startup these are both reasonable
positions what's not reasonable is to
air it out publicly it's like you ever
go to a dinner party and like some
couples fighting and you're like we're
just here to have a dinner party and you
guys are having a public disagreement
about your kids education or where
you're going to vacation or something on
the margin like you're not in couples
therapy this is a dinner party like
please stop fighting mommy and daddy
that's kind of what i think it happened
here and so part of that would be
uh the sec coming to the table and
talking to brian and the team at
coinbase in good faith and saying yeah
we'll meet with you because remember
brian seemed to be a little upset and
frustrated that they weren't meeting
with him that's kind of a reasonable
position for brian to have like
uh you know as critical as i am of
cryptocurrency i think coinbase has done
a pretty great job of making it secure
safe
um and playing by the rules so
if brian's frustrated that they won't
even meet with them well that's that's
completely reasonable like the sec is
there
and coinbase is the number one player
like they should be meeting every month
shouldn't they shouldn't they be trading
notes and discussing stuff why should
they be in a standoffish position
and so brian's right they should be
sitting down with him and clearing
things up
the sec is right that people should not
be launching these products willy-nilly
um and that there needs to be a
discussion of what are the safeguards
especially if you want to be a lender um
and if you're lending and it's a
security like this is a very important
discussion that everybody needs to have
so that's my take on it is we don't have
complete information it's like in poker
where you're trying to figure out what
your opponent's hands are or let's say
you're in a three-way pot
and somebody's raising somebody's
re-raising and then you've got aces and
you're like what's going on here and
it's like oh that plus a person's an
aggro player they might have you know
tens or jacks and they're overplaying
their hand or maybe that person hit like
two pair and they're on some crazy draw
as well and
they've got 15 16 outs and
you know they're jumping the fence and
going crazy like you have to kind of
figure out what's going on here so when
i see a news story like this there's
probably some other
party involved some lawyers who said you
know what
maybe if we say we're going to take
the len product off the table right now
then the sec would come to the table and
have a discussion with us
and we could build a relationship with
them that would result in us being the
first
you know sanctioned front of the list
person so i think it's um
you know a good idea on their part j cal
what is something unique about your
morning routine um i don't set an alarm
i just wake up naturally
so that is i think the thing that i
learned was i no longer want to set an
alarm at this age in my life and at this
like i worked hard my whole life was
like always setting alarms to get up
earlier and earlier and get more done
now i'm just like i'm waking up when i
wake up and the first meeting is at ten
and then if people don't see me they
start calling but it's very rare that i
sleep past seven or seven thirty so um
that is part of my morning routine um
and then always spending time with the
girls before they go to school i always
love to hang out with them and joke and
laugh and see them off to school and
give them hugs and that's really the
best part of my day i have to say well
actually i've been listening to the lord
of the rings with the girls every night
uh hobbit lord of the rings the
audiobooks and that is like i got to
tell you if you want to have a peak
experience
uh just laying in bed with your two
daughters the twins and listening to 45
minutes i put the sleep timer on for the
hobbit of lord of the rings and great
performances and
my daughters always fall asleep within
like 15 or 20 minutes then i go to get
up like i don't know five more minutes
five more minutes you promised i'm like
okay five minutes of overtime i sit at
the side of the bed listen to more
gandalf and
you know sam wise and the hobbit and
frodo and bilbo it's just absolutely
peak experience audiobooks is how i
really helped my daughter who's 11 my
older daughter london
um she's got
like
something like she's in the 98th
percentile in vocabulary 100 because we
wrote stories together instead of just
telling stories at night
and we listened to audiobooks constantly
and i always did audio books that were
two or three years
beyond her so like i'm with the
five-year-old twins i'm listening to
lord of the rings like they they're just
drowning in words they don't understand
and so we have a rule pause just say the
word pause i pause the audio book and we
talk about words or we rewind and listen
to things so hope you enjoy that tip
audio books with your kids jrr token
great way to bond and then you watch the
movies and it all fills in and they get
a 360 experience
if you don't have business insurance you
failed one of the first steps of being
an entrepreneur startup should look no
further than in broker and brokers
technology saves you time and money
their prices are up to 20 lower with
better coverage than the incumbents and
you can go from sign up to quote and
purchase in just 10 minutes so when you
work within broker instead of business
insurance incumbents you're not dealing
with large slow corporations and the
sign up takes days not weeks the process
is transparent with no opaque pricing so
let's talk about two very crucial types
of startup insurance you'll know that
these are very much in the news
especially the first one cyber insurance
you have to have cyber insurance which
covers hacks and they happen more than
you think a lot of them
you don't hear about publicly right
because people are ashamed to have them
happen and they should have done a
better job but mistakes happen and
sometimes software is imperfect right
where a human is imperfect and they make
a mistake they use a weak password they
forget to put two factor on well you
want to have cyber insurance just in
case that happens plus
dno insurance this helps if your
directors and officers do something dumb
and you get sued very simple very
important to have cyber and dno so to
instantly buy custom built insurance for
startups go to inbroker.com twist
e-m-d-r-o-k-e-r-d
twist while you're there you're gonna
get an extra 10 off by using the offer
code twist pwisd okay let's get back to
this amazing episode